you know after doing seven of these
videos you think that i'd be slowing
down well there's still more stuff
intended and unintended breath of the
wild discoveries are a roller coaster
that doesn't stop if you enjoy this
series let us know by liking this video
alright let's go for a ride
[Music]
lava is pretty much exclusive to either
death mountain or select shrines only
but there's a third place in hyrule that
has lava and it's literally one minute
away from the great plateau at this
pinpoint location here next to the
coliseum
this mysterious patch of lava is next to
a patch of water and isn't listed in any
game files
it's pretty rare but did you know that
wildlife such as birds and squirrels can
sometimes hide out in the hidden korok
tree holes
you can cheat your way out of giving
your horse treats and still increase
your bond with your horse simply spam b
as a horse takes a treat and you'll put
it back in your pocket reminds me of
those dog videos where they were given
invisible treats now i feel bad
these carrots at cockerico village are
protected by steen the farmer both by
game dialogue and game mechanics you can
only really examine the carrot but not
to your horsey friend who can come in
and go to town on the entire garden like
a roomba
and it's a great free way to increase
your horse bond if you don't feel too
guilty about it at least also through
normal dialogue you can find out that
steen and olken aren't best of friends
and are constantly trash talking each
other what you might not know is that
ulkan is extremely petty and at night
you can see him trample over steen's
carrot patch these carrots just cannot
catch a break
rock octa rocks are seldom seen near any
sort of water but a weird interaction is
seen when this even tight octorock
shoots its shot towards the water
it skims along the water's surface
eventually coming to a full stop without
exploding
the banner that wraps around the sides
of stables has a funny picture of a
horse doing its signature horsey grin
did you know that sometimes bokoblin's
classes prefer certain fighting styles
such as with wind cleavers lower class
ones will prefer to sit back and swing
the blade from a distance while block
and silver bokoblins almost always spin
the sword around gold ones prefer to
keep their distance as well
if you climb up link's house chimney you
can see all four divine beasts
if you get out of the way fast enough
you can start a fight between the gerudo
guards and pit them against each other
my money's on barta rocks are plentiful
and everywhere but one thing's assured
they never spawn underwater except for
this one this rock right smack dab in
the middle of martha's landing it seems
too conveniently placed right in the
middle of the bay to be a coincidence
and technically it's impossible to get
but with a glitch to disable water
collision you can go down there and
finally pick up the rock and grab its
loot underneath which nintendo dev
thought this was funny moza the terrible
cook's location on the map is a
monologue of what she's doing in the
game a pan-shaped location littered with
trash in the middle of the pan just like
her garbage cooking skills there's a
mysterious malice eyeball right beneath
this malice pile here at the banter
tower this one is all by itself and does
not free any attached malice when
destroyed
a couple rest ends in hyrule have some
funny phrases on their signs such as
kakariko villages shut eye in which says
rest your bones and goron cities rolling
in which just has snoring z's
if you look closely smother wing
butterflies have large flame designs on
the bottom of their wings i swear i've
seen this design somewhere before
all stalled enemies drawn in water just
like their normal counterparts but
normally lizalfos are water breathing
and can't drown so what do their stall
versions do they still drown but with
the i'm on fire animation instead if you
back up just a tiny bit you can just hop
straight over lisalvo's tail whip attack
have you ever wanted to be in a cozy
protective bubble while exploring at all
times if you hold deruk's protection
walking around can become pretty clumsy
because you're constantly in the
defensive stance but if you keep holding
zl then just tap magnesis or stasis on
and off you can walk and run around
normally
there are some documents from nintendo
that shows their planning and design for
how horses detect and jump over
obstacles ahead of itself depending on
the speed the horse is currently at
which must be a pretty complex system
given the thousands of situations horses
face while riding around in the
overworld this development test here was
done east of the great plateau
[Music]
lynx swims faster without clothes on if
he wears heavy armor his swim speed is
reduced significantly to navigate around
this you can use a speed buff potion to
swim faster funny thing is is that swim
speed buffs do not work while you have
no clothes on so you have to have at
least one piece of equipment on you for
the speed buff to work
well time to put on tingle's hat
did you know that the bokoblin maublin
and lizolfo's mask actually changes
link's hurtbox there aren't too many
uses for it in actual gameplay though
but it's still a small neat detail
if you stasis a disguised yiga assassin
while they're doing their dash attack
moving to a specific angle to their left
or right will cause them to continue to
dash around you forever
okay that's enough
[Music]
there's been a glitch found recently
that has some really strange properties
if you use a campfire aim the camera
away from enemies then watch a memory
they'll be loaded in but invisibly
shooting this load block with ice arrows
or fire arrows then doing a menu action
loads them back in permanently on fire
or frozen but still able to move around
like nothing's wrong
a side effect of the frozen enemy
version is that they become extremely
light and even large enemies such as
moblins are able to be launched upwards
by any updraft
also any equipment with cloth physics
they pick up go kind of wonky
if you clip through the walls of shrines
you're able to escape the map and fall
into a never-ending abyss as time passes
link becomes more and more distorted
over time and pretty soon just becomes a
wall of pixels if you're wondering if
this abyss has a bottom though user
drill caramari started falling back on
march 8th of 2020 and has since then
never turned his console off he is still
falling to this day updating the status
every once in a while
you can fly through this tiny window at
hyrule castle
some people still don't know that the
choo choo's weak spot is its eyeballs
there's a process with the glitch that
has really interesting effects and it
puts you into the shoes of wildlife
without mods by freezing yourself as you
talk to someone then riding over to an
animal and then trying to mount it he
will take over their point of view doing
this trick with the lynel you can
finally see what it's like to become a
lionel now that i see this from their
angle i can see how annoying it must
feel to be shot by link's pesky arrows
yeah you think that's funny link come
over here and say it to my face
cass has some sheet music that is
partially readable on his hip
unfortunately each sheet is rolled up
and only half of the page of music is
readable so it doesn't make much sense
when it's actually played out
[Music]
but if you can find a reference within
these half pages let us know
this lynel at gerudo summit is the only
one that carries normal arrows and with
the wooden shield with durability
transferred can be farmed for arrows now
these final two tips are above spoilers
so be warned dark be scanning's massive
laser burns grass and creates updrafts
but its effects are different from a
normal fire the grass burned if you look
closely is lifeless and flattened from
ganon's evil compared to normal grass's
burn state dark beast ganon's weak
points can be hit in several different
ways such as a bow of light obviously
twilight bow master sword beam and even
urbosa's fury
and that's a wrap if you enjoyed this
series check out our breath of the wild
expert series playlist with tons of
breath of the wild tidbits you never
knew about and for everything else
gaming stay tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
you